Фрідланд. Це містечко на кордоні
Нижньої Саксонії і Гессена
вважається "ворітьми в Німеччину" для етнічних німців.
Через цей центр з прийому біженців і переселенців
проходить кожен, хто сьогодні виїжджає
на історичну батьківщину з країн колишнього СРСР.
Останніми роками число таких людей знову збільшується.
Центр може прийняти одночасно до 800 осіб.
Один з постояльців - Дмитро Білий.
Разом з родиною він переїхав з Одеси
на початку лютого.
У Нижній Саксонії вже десять років живуть їхні родичі.
Залишити Україну родина Дмитра вирішила приблизно рік тому.
Німецьку вчили з нуля.
У ФРН їх найбільше вражають відносини між людьми.
Привітність. Саме не ввічливість, а привітність людей.
Чуйність. На будь-яке твоє прохання, людина готова
допомогти абсолютно всім. Це саме те,
чого мені не вистачає у своєму середовищі проживання,
скажімо так.
Для нас пріоритет - це дитинство наших дітей та їхнє майбутнє.
В першу чергу поїхали через це.
Умови життя були достатні для існування,
але не для розвитку, як нашого, так і наших дітей.
Тому ми захотіли більшого. Кращого майбутнього.
Добре, що була можливість, тому й поїхали.
Дружину Дмитра звуть Олена. Вона не жалкує, що зважилась на переїзд.
На батьківщині ми займали непогані посади,
і заробіток був вищий середнього, але попри це,
ми не мали такої можливості й часу,
щоб дати гідне існування своїм дітям.
Перебуваючи тут, нехай і недовго, мені імпонує цей порядок,
організованість цієї країни.
Закони, які працюють, на відміну від нашої країни.
Директор приймального пункту порядкує тут більше двадцяти років.
Він каже, що родини, як ось ця з Одеси -
типові представники нової хвилі міграції з колишнього СРСР.
На початку 90-х приїжджали великі родини, іноді до двадцяти осіб.
Люди похилого віку з дітьми, онуками, для яких це був перший візит до Німеччини.
Сьогоднішні переселенці приїжджають з чіткими очікуваннями.
Майже у всіх є родичі, які вже давно живуть у Німеччині.
В них є інформація, вони знають, що на них чекає.
У філії Федерального адміністративного відомства,
яке оформлює документи етнічних німців,
так пояснюють зростання числа переселенців.
З 2013 року діє новий закон,
який дозволяє возз'єднатися багатьом родинам, які свого часу були розділені.
Цим правилом користуються все більше людей.
Харчування та проживання для переселенців у центрі безкоштовне.
Вони проводять тут кілька днів, щоб владнати формальності
та отримати документи.
Головне питання, яке вирішується у центрі - нове місце проживання
- федеральна земля і конкретний населений пункт.
Олена з Одеси вже має чіткий план дій.
Шукати житло, яке надасть нам держава на час адаптації.
Реєструватися. Вчити мову.
Шукати школу для дітей і садки.
Дмитру та Олені залишилося отримати готові документи,
з якими вони вирушать на нове місце проживання -
місто Пайне у Нижній Саксонії.